Welcome to the DDPS
seminar, everyone. It is an
honor to your host, Paul
Atzberger, who is currently a
professor at the Department of
Mathematics of University of
California, Santa Barbara.
All right, thank you, like thank
the organizers for this
opportunity to talk today, I
thought I would share a little
bit of work that we've been
doing on leveraging recent
developments in generative
modeling, and particular machine
learning approaches that have
been emerging, especially in the
deep learning community, for the
purposes of developing
multiscale models, reductions
and other types of
representations for nonlinear
dynamical systems have larger
scientific simulations, you
know, so fluid mechanics,
materials, modeling, and so on.
So I'm going to talk about a
rather sort of small piece of
the work that we're doing. And
this is relatively recent work.
And I'd be very happy to
continue discussions offline
about various directions and
applications. So just to set a
little bit, the context in which
I'm motivated in developing
these data driven methods, is,
what we're really after are ways
that we can utilize observations
either taken from experiment or
higher fidelity computational
simulations, and really use data
driven perspectives to
essentially learn
representations, which we can
use as a simulator either to
predict future behaviors of the
system, or in the context of a
much larger calculation where
perhaps the part of the model
that we're interested in
replacing is very
computationally expensive to
compute at a high level of
detail. But for the purposes of
larger scale phenomena that
we're interested in a much sort
of coarsened or simplified model
would potentially do the trick.
But it might be very difficult
to arrive at that through kind
of traditional asymptotic
techniques. And so what I'm also
interested in is in doing this
in the context, not only of
deterministic systems, but
stochastic systems. And that's
primarily what I'll talk about
today, I feel like again, to
build some context, I need to
say a little bit about
techniques that are out there
and have been successfully
applied for this type of
problem. So they can kind of
compare a little bit and
contrast some of the objectives
of the techniques that we're
developing. And so there's been
a lot of work done over the
years, of course, a data driven
modeling of dynamics, probably
one of the most notable one is
this proper orthogonal
decomposition. This is
essentially a form of principal
component analysis, where the
basic strategy to build up your
dynamical model, I'm here, I'm
just showing a fluid mechanics
model on the upper right would
be to look at the modes in the
system, essentially, that vary
the most. So essentially, you
would take your flow field
create this very high
dimensional point cloud, and
effectively you're doing
principal component and on that
a really nice development in the
direction of incorporating
dynamics within this kind of
linear frameworks is the dynamic
mode decomposition, introduced
by Schmid in 2010. And lots of
developments by by various
groups and communities,
including Bronto, and Coots, in
various directions. And again,
this is a linear based model.
Again, that's there's a lot of
advantages. Having linear base
models, they're much more
straightforward to build theory
for and, you know, potentially
computationally efficient, that
more efficient than training,
let's say, deep neural networks.
And so the basic idea in things
like dynamic mode decomposition
is you're basically going to
take dynamical information into
account by saying, well, which
modes are sort of most
indicative of that prediction of
what's going to happen in the
future over some set of
snapshots. So you're basically
looking for, again, the sort of
best linear model and kind of
the best basis in order to try
to align your your linear
predictor with the underlying
data observations. There has
also been really nice work done
on using symbolic approaches,
essentially, l one regression
things like the lawsuit combined
with the symbolic dictionaries,
and that's a way that you can
overcome some of the issues that
I mentioned in these previous
linear models. And again, lots
of successes and nice
applications of these
techniques. And but you know,
this has the drawback that you
do need an sufficiently
expressive library so that you
can have coverage over the space
of potential dynamic
representations that are
relevant for your system. So my
main point of mentioning these
approaches, I just want to give
kind of some context of what's
out there. And it kind of just
helps set a little bit, the the
overarching environment in which
we're trying to develop these
data driven techniques, I'm also
gonna incorporate noise. So
they'll also be a generative
component that I'll be talking
about in detail. And so the
objective is, try to not just
recapitulate the behavior that
you're seeing in the training
set, but really learn for
intrinsic model, so that you can
make either longer term
predictions, or ideally, in the
context of a lot of these
scientific computing
applications, be able to replace
one of your more expensive
models with one that's much
cheaper by a longtime simulator.
And so that poses a lot of
challenges from the data driven
modeling perspective, because,
you know, depending on how you
go about this, your model class
might not have certain intrinsic
properties that we're used to
when we design into our
numerical methods, you know,
such as things like stability,
which obviously be very
important for longtime
prediction. Also, another
challenge is incorporating prior
knowledge to the extent that we
can, we often know a lot about,
you know, the physics of the
system or other mathematical
structure in a system. And so
we'd also like ways of including
that as inductive biases in our
data driven methods. So we'll
talk a little bit about where I
think there are opportunities to
do that as well, in some of
these nonlinear approximation
approaches, as I said, these
developments in the neural
networks community in particular
generative models, and I'll kind
of put it in a little bit
larger, probabilistic context.
And and there's a lot of
interesting directions, I think
that this can be pursued for for
a lot of the applications that I
showed on the previous slides.
But going beyond, again, that
sort of linear approximations to
that incorporate various types
of nonlinear approximation
classes. So as to motivate the
examples, and I'll come back and
I'll give some results for
these. One of which is, you
know, basically systems
identification, or extracting
state information, which is
important in many different
problems, including things like
control. And the objective here
basically, is to learn key
parameters, from observations of
the dynamics. These things go
by, you know, many different
names, depending on the
community this. Now what we're
trying to utilize here, as I
showed in the upper right, just
a little animation, if I'm
trying to learn, for example, in
this Orenstein lindbeck process,
you can think of it intuitively
from the mechanics point of
view, as a bead spring system,
where I'm trying to learn
simultaneously, the stiffness,
the damping and the temperature
of the system, you know, what we
want to do is somehow probe the
dynamics in a way that would be
indicative of those different
properties. So there's going to
be an interesting challenge,
whenever you're trying to
estimate a model from the
dynamics that you may, you have
to be careful basically, that
you're probing the dynamics on
the appropriate timescales, and
that you have sufficient
coverage over the response range
that would be sensitive to those
particular parameters. But the
overall objective here is to try
to learn dynamical
representations from
observations, sample
trajectories. Also in reductions
and course grading. I'll show an
example where, you know, we're
trying to learn essentially
unknown force laws. And so how
that can be done again, for this
general perspective. In this
case, this would be a
nonparametric estimation problem
where we want to learn an
unknown force law, for example,
in something like lunch, Yvonne
dynamics, and so problems
analogous to this come up in a
lot of different contexts, in
developing again, reductions, so
that you can simulate things on
larger timescales to overcome,
for example, sources of
stiffness, or in coarse grained
modeling, of course, which is
very popular, for example, in
the material sciences community.
So some of the interesting
things that you could
potentially do if you had good
nonlinear estimation methods is,
you know, not have to handcraft
your estimators for things like
the the force law. So one of the
common ways you might try to go
about doing this is to use
something like maximum
likelihood estimation. But of
course, the immediate challenge
you run into in the setting of
these dynamic representations is
that you have to specify
likelihood functions, you have
to compute those potentially on
very high dimensional
probability spaces. And so I'm
going to show some alternatives
to that approach. Alright, so I
just wanted to give some of the
kind of key key motivations here
and context of where we're
trying to develop these
techniques just to give a, a
sort of overview of some of the
issues that arise. And I think
there's a lot of potentially
interesting ways, again, to
leverage a lot of the recent
developments in the machine
learning community. In the case
of stochastic dynamics, in some
sense, we're trying to learn an
entire ensemble. And so there'll
be some interesting issues that
arise there, given the roles
that noise plays in stochastic
phenomena. And then, of course,
as I said before, we'd like to
do all of this to obtain robust
representations that are stable
for the purposes of either
longtime prediction or
simulation. Alright, so I think
I've said, you know, enough at
the sort of the high level, and
I'll start getting into some of
the more details of the
techniques that we're going to
leverage and did further
develop. So if you're not
familiar with generative
adversarial networks, I'm just
gonna go through really quick,
what these techniques are these
recent developments in the
machine learning community,
closely related to generative
modeling statistics. And so what
I'm going to do is just go
through perspective on
generative adversarial networks.
This is basically a way for us
to train a simulator or an
implicit generative model, that
is this function that I'm
showing here, which is g of z.
And g of z basically has some
noise source. And what it's
going to do is generate a sort
of collection of samples. And
the objective here is to take
our training data and take our
implicit generator and have some
way of comparing the samples
that we get from the the
training set with the samples
that were produced by the
generator. Now as I mentioned
before, you know One way that
this is traditionally be done,
if you know a lot analytically
about the generator is you could
use things like maximum
likelihood estimation. But if
you do that, right, this
requires the specification of
likelihood functions requires
you to go and perform those
calculations during the training
loop, which could potentially be
quite quite challenging. The
appeal of doing this adversarial
training approach is instead of
relying on a sort of pre
specified likelihood function,
what we're going to do is
simultaneously train another
model. This could potentially as
well be a neural network, but
can be taken from any model
class you like. And I'll show a
little bit about that in a
minute. And basically, the job
of this discriminator is to
characterize how closely the
samples that were produced by
the generator differ. And so the
discriminator, you can think of
as playing a role analogous to a
classifier. And if I have this
collection of samples, its job
is to say, Well, did those
samples come from the training
set or the generator, if they
can distinguish that readily,
then your you know, your
generator needs to be improved,
you can think of this as kind of
like a two player game, where if
I had a classifier loss, for
example, the discriminator would
be aiming to minimize the loss,
while the generator would be
aiming to maximize that loss for
the discriminator. And so by
making different choices of the
discriminator, we can actually
realize different divergences
and metrics for comparing the
empirical measures of the
samples of generator with with
that of the training data
distribution. Alright, so that's
a quick overview of of GaNS. So
you have a generator G, what's
different from some of the other
modeling approaches is, we're
not actually going to write down
ever the probability
distribution or measure
directly, we're simply going to
have an algorithm that generates
from some random input samples,
and then we're gonna tune
essentially that algorithm, so
that it produces high quality
samples that agree with the
training set, and then
discriminator, the simplest case
would be a binary classifier,
which I'll use for illustration,
and then I'll, I'll show how we
can extend that. And for the
purposes of these learning of
dynamics, if it were a binary
classifier, basically, the idea
would be it would give us a
number, maybe between zero and
one telling us the probability
that it thinks it was produced
by the data distribution versus
produced by the the implicit
generator. So I'm going to write
these probability densities down
for the purposes of having a
theoretical perspective. But in
practice, you're only going to
be working with samples from G
and D will only be operating on
sample sets from from G and the
in the training set. So
basically, you can think about a
little bit like a it's like a
little game where G is kind of
acting like a counterfeiter, D
is kind of a classifier, seeing
whether this is real or fake.
And your job is to create such
good samples again, that the
discriminator can't can't tell.
Alright, and well, we'll see
what that how that plays out
mathematically, in a little bit.
And, and that'll inform our
choices for the discriminator
model classes. All right, so the
way that we're going to
typically play this game is what
we'll do is we'll have a
synthetic data set, which is a
mixture of samples that are
taken from the generator samples
that are taking from the from
the training set, and those get
mixed together. And we put label
one on everything from the
training set, and we put labels
zero on everything from the
implicit generator, and now in
leverage results from the
classification theory to create
a loss function for the
discriminator Model D. And so
they score of the discriminator
is basically going to be, you
know, the 01 loss for assigning
the correct labels to those
sample points. Now, if we look
at it from, you know, point of
view of let's say, the Bayesian
classifier, you can see that if
d of x is interpreted as a
probability, the ideal way to
try to classify would be for D
to estimate the probability that
the label is one given that
sample point because you know,
you could have that both the
generator and the data
distribution produce the exact
same sample, of course, in
practice, there'll be a little
bit of smoothness that needs to
come into the problem, you know,
where you want this for x's that
are close that they have the
appropriate probability
assigned. And then one minus d
is basically the probability of
the label y was assigned. So of
course, the Bayes classifier
would be to just take the arg
max of that conditional
probability, what we're
basically trying to do is
develop an algorithm to find
effectively that Bayesian
classifier for this mixed
synthetic data set which which
is acting in for the class of
ours point of view is
effectively like a training set.
But I call it synthetic training
or synthetic label data, just
not just to distinguish the
original data from this
synthetic one that we're using
for the purposes of the GaNS.
And so if we mixed together one
half probability, the things
from the generator and one half
probability from the the
original training data, this
would be the gist distribution
that we're training the
discriminator over. And the
Bayes classifier actually can be
worked out analytically to be
this. So it'll essentially just
be the probability of the data
distribution generating that
sample over the sum of the
probabilities of the data in the
model distributions having
generated that probability. So
you can see that the optimal if
we were to actually perform all
of our optimization perfectly,
the best discriminator, the one
that would minimize the loss,
the 01 loss would be given by
this analytic expression here.
Of course, in practice, we don't
get that. But some interesting
outcomes you see is that if I
had that the data is crucial in
the model attribution lined up
perfectly, I would have that
this d of x is one half. And
that kind of means that the
discriminator was maximally
confused, didn't know whether it
should assign a label of zero or
one is the way you can
intuitively interpret that. So
if you now go and you get a
little more mathematical about
what we're actually computing,
here, we have this objective
function, the theta d, here are
the parameters for the model
class of the discriminator. And
the theta g, here are the
parameters of the model class of
the generator, what we're
basically minimizing in the loss
function is this expectation of
the log label probability here,
this is the usual 01 loss, this
is what that that amounts to.
And now if you break it down for
what we have, for the synthetic
set dataset, you'll see that it
breaks into these two parts. And
this is the typical loss that
would be used for discriminator.
In something like, again, now
we're gonna see, there's some
drawbacks to this. And I'm gonna
have to reformulate the GaNS for
the purposes of learning these
stochastic systems. But I wanted
to kind of show you the sort of
standard and original
formulation before I do those
modifications. So at the end of
the day, what you'd be doing is
trying to find an ARG min of
this objective function to get
your discriminator. Basically,
you're trying to have the best
classifier possible given that
synthetic data set, and then the
generators job is basically to
try to mess up the
discriminators ability to
achieve a low loss. In other
words, make your sample so good
looking that the discriminator
really can't tell between the
samples it's producing, and
those of the data distribution.
So that's sort of the underlying
strategy. And this is how it
plays out mathematically, I've
used a little bit of a modified
objective here just to avoid
some issues with vanishing
gradients. But nonetheless,
that's what this objective is
ultimately achieving, when you
arg max it with respect to the
generators, parameters, you
know, very prone to oscillations
if you use kind of this
alternative descent asset. But
anyway, I just wanted to mention
what the typical training
objective is. And we're going to
use some analytic techniques to
work around that issue of
oscillations that arises, I'm
just showing an example with
learning something which is
relatively simple, which is a
Gaussian. But the key point I
really want to make here is you
don't know in advance,
typically, what is a good noise
noise source. And so the real
sort of issue here is the noise
source I took to be a uniform
distribution, I want to compute
something like a Gaussian,
you'll see that even trying to
train a model that's this
simple, GaNS runs into some and
you see immediately that you get
a lot of oscillations during
training. And really what's
going on here is it's very
difficult often in ganz to to
resolve the tails, especially if
you don't have a decaying noise
source. But you know, you could
replace this obviously, with a
Gaussian noise source, and you'd
very readily be able to learn
the model. But this is really
the scenario that you often
encounter in practice is the
noise source often needs to
undergo some pretty radical
transformations in order to
realize the target probability
distribution. So we want to be
very careful about the the
objectives that we're using to
train the GaNS. And there's this
issue of oscillations if we use
simply this relaxation, this
gradient descent for
discriminator, great asset for
the generators. And so what
we've done is introduced a way
to modify the standard
formulation of GaNS to
incorporate some additional
features to deal with some of
those issues related to
oscillations to deal with some
of the issues related to the
noise that I mentioned, as well
as the the high dimensionality.
And so we refer to this as
stochastic dynamic GaNS. So the
basic objective, again, is to
learn implicit generator, a
generative model GMC here, x
would now be the trajectories
and we'd like to be again,
sample bass, so we'll use this
setup with discriminators. Now,
if you observe stochastic
trajectories, the reason why I
can't just use the standard GaNS
formulation is the dynamic
trajectories would be very, very
high dimensional random
variables. And so you can
imagine it being very prone to
not having good sample coverage.
In fact, if you do the standard
against formulation that I
showed before, you can show that
that loss that you ultimately
get is based on callback leibler
divergence, you have to be very
careful about probability
distributions being absolutely
continuous with respect to the
other. And so as a consequence,
getting coverage in the sample
space would be quite challenging
when you go to very high
dimensions. And so we're We're
gonna do is we're going to use
the probabilistic structure that
we often know in advance about
dynamical systems, for example,
you know, if we're looking at
something like longevity
dynamics, we know that the new
state is likely to depend on
some previous number of states,
in that case, two states. And so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to develop my learning methods
over the class of general M
step, stochastic integrators.
And that's going to be the model
class, essentially, for my
implicit generators. And by
doing that, I can sort of build
in various inductive biases,
including a learning within,
let's say, the framework of
numerical methods, which are
known to be stable, at least for
sufficiently small time steps.
And, and basically, from that, I
can then learn my
representations in a way where I
have a viable candidate
simulator in hand. So from the
modeling point of view, or
probabilistic point of view, you
can think about us learning over
essentially, probabilistic
graphical models, where we're
going to allow for state k,
there to be a dependence on the
previous steps. Okay, so that's
going to be the basic way that
we deal with some of these high
dimensionality issues. And then
I'll talk about how that
probabilistic structure, not
only can we use for the full
trajectory, but we also can look
at trajectory fragments, as the
signatures that we use in the
discriminator to drive the
generator towards the data
distribution samples. So the key
idea here is really we want to,
we want to be completely sample
based, so we can avoid having to
specify likelihood functions. So
throughout, there will be no
likelihood function. So you can
think about these as being
methods that are alternatives to
maximum likelihood estimation.
Alright, so learn
representations I'm going to use
as my model class stochastic M
step methods. So just to get
some notation specified. This is
just saying that voting this
probabilistic graphical
structure I'm showing here on
the right, we'll have that state
j depends on the previous M
states, you can think of SY j
minus one as the update from
time step, or step j minus one
to J, omega j, here will be the
sample point because we're
dealing with a stochastic
process. And then the P here
will be whatever parameters we
have of the system. So these
could be your weights of neural
networks, or they could be
parameters of the physical
system that you'd like to learn
from your trajectory
observations also allow the
parameters to influence the the
initial conditions, where you
could think about that is coming
from some ensemble for the
initial conditions of the
system. Alright, so that's the
basic setup in the model class
that we're going to use for our
implicit generators. And this
provides all kinds of ways to
incorporate prior knowledge,
physical principles, we can sort
of design into this update all
kinds of features, I'm going to
replace the standard kind of
Jenson Shannon divergence
approach of the original GaNS
formulation with another
approach that's kernel based.
And that will also provide some
other ways to incorporate
inductive biases. And then as I
said before, this encodes
essentially these probabilistic
dependencies. So we're not
learning over the general space
of you know, our n times d
random variables, we're really
learning over this class of
graphical models. Now, once you
do that, there's also a way to
introduce different training
protocols realize you can train
this quite effectively, not just
using the full trajectory data,
but also using things like
conditional distributions, or
even just marginal
distributions. And this allows
for potentially big reductions
in the number of dimensions you
have to deal with during the
training process, because you
can utilize trajectory
fragments. And so I'll show some
results there, as well as
downsampling by using different
timescales tab. So the overall
objective then is going to be to
develop appropriate
discriminators and critics for
this sort of dynamic scenario.
Currently, what we're developing
are methods within the context
of generalized moment methods or
maximum mean discrepancy. And,
and we found in practice, this
seems to lead to some nice
results with respect to avoiding
some of those oscillations like
I showed you in the standard
GaNS formulation. Alright, so
those three training protocols,
I'll just say a little bit about
them briefly, because they'll
kind of come back when I develop
some of the algorithms. So in
the full trajectory case,
essentially, what we're going to
think of as the implicit
generators distribution would
just be essentially the sequence
of snapshots of the dynamic
trajectory. And of course,
that's going to be very high
dimensional. And that's not very
desirable in training. Because,
you know, again, getting sample
coverage in a high dimensional
space is, is quite challenging.
So you need rather large batches
to get meaningful comparisons.
So what we're going to do often
is downselect in two different
ways, delta t here that I
mentioning, doesn't necessarily
have to be the time step of the
M step generator. This could be
much larger time step so that
you're only sampling at you
know, select times and that way
you can get sensitivity to the
dynamic responses on large
timescales, but the underlying
Numerix is using a much smaller
or substep. And so that's the
strategy we will typically use
with these full trajectory
approaches. And that's what's
being denoted here by this tau
that you're seeing there. And so
the conditional methods, as the
name implies, this will be where
we'll use a trajectory
fragments, this would be most
appropriate where we're able to
generate entries of the training
set from something like a high
fidelity simulation. So these
would start off with like the
same local initial conditions
and then evolve for some period
of time, it's kind of like a
little local burst, if you like,
of trajectories. And then of
course, you're learning these
probability distributions, which
are conditionals, on those
different samples for the
initial conditions, and that
that has, obviously training
benefits. Again, if you have
some control over initializing
the training data set data, and
then the marginals don't require
that the marginal simply just
take a fragment of the
trajectories. And essentially,
you're just trying to learn
marginal distributions for some
specified ranges, you can either
do it as kind of like a sliding
window, or you could have it at
one specific time. So the main
point I really want to make is
there's all kinds of interesting
variations and combinations of
what I've specified here, that
can be used to greatly improve
potentially training when you're
trying to learn these stochastic
dynamical models. And so I'll
focus on these kind of three
standard cases. Alright, so for
the generator loss, I'm going to
reformulate it. So I'm not
simply using a 01 classifier,
and this is with the objective
of trying to get a little bit
more information about the
dynamical track trajectories
that can be used as a learning
signal in the gradient of the
generator. And so what I'm going
to do is, instead of using just
a sort of binary classifier, I'm
instead going to learn a critic
or a discriminator. That is
essentially a function, which is
going to aim to distinguish
between the two probability
distributions. So you can think
about this function as basically
being like a signature that
tells me how different these two
random variables are, where the
function is restricted to come
from some range of features or
functional forms. And I'll get
into that in more detail. From
the probability and statistics
literature. This is what's known
as an integral probability
metric. Depending how you choose
this model class fancy if you're
you can get all kinds of
interesting metrics, including
the Kentaro vix metric
associated with optimal
transport, like the Wasserstein
metric, for example, that would
be the one Lipschitz functions
for its constant less than or
equal to one, you can make other
choices to get other well known
metrics and divergences, the
choice that we're going to make
here and again, the whole
purpose of this is to compare
the empirical distribution of
the generator and the training
set, we're going to use a
reproducing kernel Hilbert space
for F, for f here, and we're
looking at all of the functions
that have norm in that space
less than or equal to one. So
there's a number of nice things
that happen if we use that
depending on our choice of
kernel. This, of course, can
give us rather rich ability to
distinguish between probability
distributions, while at the same
time having some other structure
which we can utilize for the
purposes of training from these
finite sample sets. A lot of
what will happen here is, it'll
be similar to doing something
like a kernel density estimate
of the two distributions and
kind of comparing their
difference. But of course, what
currently you choose will affect
what's being emphasized in those
comparisons. So the key property
that I'm going to use for that
kernel for now, I'll just leave
the kernel generic. And I'll say
a little bit more about what we
use, when I get into the
examples is we'll use the fact
that if we're going to
reproducing kernel Hilbert
space, then we can evaluate the
function f at a particular value
x, by simply taking the inner
product of f with the kernel.
Now using that property, if I
substitute that in above here,
it actually can be, I can
simplify the form of this
optimization problem that I need
to solve. I'll use the notation
up, you can think about this as
an embedding of the first
probability distribution, and mu
Q as an embedding of the second
probability distribution into
the reproducing kernel Hilbert
space, I can use that along with
this kernel property to
basically commute the the inner
product with the expectation.
And if I do that, then this
integral probability metric that
I get can be expressed in this
form. This is what's known as
maximum mean discrepancy. And
you can see readily now that
optimizing over all norm one
functions would be given by
simply taking the direction of
that second vector or that
second function. And that's
simply given by the difference
between the embeddings over the
norm of the embeddings. And so
when you work it all out, you
know, again, going back and
using this property of kernels,
you can express this as the sum
of kernel expectations. Now, all
that looks great. The one
drawback of course of this is
that these are second order
statistics and we'll talk about
how we'll deal with that in a
little bit. And so this provides
us then from A sample based
point of view, this would
provide us with a loss function
for our generator, in
particular, we can take this
expectation quantity, let's just
square it to get rid of the
square root. Since at the end of
the day, we're interested in
doing optimization minimizing
and and then we can use this
unbiased estimator here, which
would then give us a sample
based estimate of the MMD. And
so that's what we're going to
use for our generator loss. This
is basically a way of
determining the discriminator
analytically, so I don't have to
go through a separate training
or optimization problem, like I
did in the standard GaNS
formulation. So now that takes
the discriminator optimization
part out of the problem. And now
I can focus on simply minimizing
or minimizing the objective for
the implicit generator. And so
that'll boil down to this loss
function, which I'm showing
here, which will amount to
essentially the the the
empirical estimator for the MMD
that I'm showing in the upper
right. And this is just
computing NMD, the unbiased
estimator for effectively those
empirical distributions of G and
D. Alright, so that's going to
be the overall loss that I'm
going to use in my generative
formulation. Now, it boils down
to how do I actually compute
this in practice for performing
training using things like
Stochastic gradient descent, and
so what's really crucial here is
that I'd be able to compute
gradients of that loss function
efficiently. And it turns out
that if I use just standard back
propagation methods of the
computational collagraphs, it
should become prohibitively
large for backprop. So I'm going
to make use of more mathematical
structure of this loss function.
And so the first observation is
just to note that we have to do
these double sums over the
samples not very computationally
efficient, again, if we were to
use sort of direct backprop on
the computed expressions, but we
have a lot of probabilistic
dependency or that we know in
advance, we know that the sample
points, for example, come from
those M step updates, we know a
lot about the structure of the
objective function coming from
the the kernel evaluations that
I showed you before. And so, you
know, again, high dimensions,
having to deal with these second
order statistics. And that's
what I'm going to address next.
So the basic approach that we're
going to take is closely related
to Agile methods. And we're
going to use that in a judicious
way, both for computing aspects
of the second order statistics,
as well as the dependence on the
stochastic trajectories. And in
this way, then we'll have a
viable training protocol for
learning over those M step
methods with these MMD losses.
So just to give a quick overview
of those techniques, what we're
doing is, we're ultimately
trying to compute gradients of
an expectation. And so the way
that we'll look at this from a
mathematical perspective is
we'll build all of the
dependencies into the parameters
p that we're trying to learn
into the random variable. So
we'll assume there's some base
measure, I call that omega, you
can view then the expectation,
on our case, it's the MMD, that
we're taking expectations of the
stochastic trajectories are
being generated by an implicit
generator that has some
parameters p. So the random
variable is what has the P
dependence, not the base
measure. And in that case, then
we can compute taking gradients
in the expected quantity with
taking expectations of the
gradient of the random variable,
essentially. So that's just the
key assumption that we're going
to make an our notation,
essentially, or formulation. And
of course, what we're doing here
is a discrete approximation of
that expectation and follows, as
shown here on the right to
effectively being able to
compute gradients of the sample
terms. Okay. So now if you look
at the gradients of the sample
terms, the problematic part is
having to create gradients in
the stochastic trajectory
components. And if you were to
go through again, and kind of do
this in a straightforward way,
using the chain rule, this
becomes rather expensive,
because you would compute
gradients and all the different
stochastic trajectories, and
then ultimately contract them
with these partials x and v. And
so it turns out, and this is an
insight that's used in Agile
approaches, control theory and
other areas, it turns out that
because you're doing this
contraction, there's actually an
alternative formulation of the
contribution of this term. And
I'll walk you through how that
plays out in the context of, of
our methods. So the challenge is
to compute efficiently the
contributions of those gradients
in p of the sample set. So as
you adjust the parameters of the
stochastic model, right, that's
going to affect all of the
samples that are produced. And
that's what we need to deal
with. So the alternative
approach that we're going to
take is going to be based on an
Agilent formulation. And really,
what we're going to utilize is
the fact that if you look at the
solution to that M step method,
you see that it solves this
implicit equation here. And so
we're F has these components.
And if we do that this implicit
formulation allows us to utilize
the implicit function theorem,
which basically says that if we
take a derivative in the
parameters, we can express it in
this way using the total
derivative, and we can actually
solve for XP in terms of
derivatives of f. So we've kind
of shifted everything off to the
Let's hit function f, instead of
having to compute in terms of x
p directly, and that has a bunch
of nice properties, as you'll
see, because now what I can do
is I can contract this
expression quite readily. And
often I'll get a problem that's
much easier to solve than if I
had constructed all of those
explicit gradients. Alright, so
then x p can be expressed in
terms of the G Cobian. In this
way, in terms of derivatives of
the implicit function, f.
Alright, so I've just copied
that over here on the left. And
the Agilent approach is to
compute them the full derivative
by plugging in this expression
for x p, and then just
rearranging the order in which
you're going to do the
contractions. And if you do
that, then you can show that
this whole expression will boil
down to essentially contracting
a vector r with F p, where r
satisfies this equation. So the
real challenge, then I would
say, is to come up with an
efficient way to compute each of
the steps in this gradient
computation, which is to compute
g x f x, that gets you the G
Cobian. Have an efficient solver
for our then compute GP FP. And
then now you get your full
gradient through combining those
terms with that solution, or
it's really the computation of
our that's typically the part
that that can get
computationally expensive. I'll
show you in the context of these
M step methods, we actually can
get very efficient algorithms,
in fact, a solver which amounts
to solving a system of
recurrence equations to
construct that vector. Alright,
so that's the objective, and an
old that will be used to compute
the gradients of these empirical
estimators of the expectation.
Alright, so just to get through
that the second order
statistics, I don't want to say
too much about that, you can
basically use the chain rule.
And again, if you judiciously
look at what you get, it turns
out that you can reduce things
to essentially doing an adjoint
method on this linear function.
I won't say very much about it,
but you can use the technique
that I showed you on the
previous slide, to construct
them derivatives of the
overarching loss. So the real
challenge then comes up to
having effective adjuvant
methods for the stochastic
trajectories. And so I'll focus
on that just in the interest of
time. And so up there on the
upper left is the gradient
method. This is the implicit
formulation, including the
initial conditions, I'll go
through this rather quick
because I do want to have
sufficient time to talk about
results, you can look at our
paper for a lot of the details,
but just some notation, f j, D
will be the the implicit
equation for the J step and DT
component. And then when I take
the derivative, I'll just put
that second index there. So
putting all these pieces
together, what you basically
have to compute is for these
implicit equations, you have to
compute the following two
Cobian, that's done rather
straightforwardly using these
FJD f k, d prime terms. And you
take the transpose, this gives
you a set of linear systems, I'm
going to break the our vector
down into components
corresponding to this steps at
the end of the directory all the
way back to the beginning. So
what I'm really utilizing here
is that probabilistic dependency
that I have, in particular, the
form of these updates, and so if
I do that, I can first compute R
n, then use that to compute r n
minus one all the way down to R
zero, put all those together
composite that will get me R.
And I can use that in my
gradient calculation to get the
updates. So that's the strategy
here, I realize I'm going a
little quick, but I just in the
interest of time, want to go
through this briefly. And I'll
refer you to the paper for a
more in depth discussion. So at
the end step, you basically have
this particular equation for the
RN components, you can solve
that outright in terms of
derivatives of fee. Now you have
that if you go to step n minus
one and minus two, and so on
back, you can again solve
directly for our k d, you put
everything here on the right
hand side, notice those indexes
are plus one, plus L, so you
have those in hand from the
previous step. And then of
course, if you're more than m
steps away from the end point,
then you get this generic
formula that, again, allows you
to solve for RK in terms of the
previous iterates that you
already have in hand. So this
gives you a very efficient
solver now to get our and that's
sort of the key component in our
gradient calculations for doing
Stochastic gradient descent of
this this generative modeling
approach. Alright, I'll refer
you to the papers again, for
details there.
And I've already said a lot
about the training protocols.
And these can be obviously
adapted and applied quite
readily within each of these
contexts. Alright, so let me in
the remaining conference, talk a
bit about some of our early
results with these methods. As I
mentioned, it's pretty recent
and ongoing work. So the first
problem I mentioned was learning
parameters of mechanical
systems. And in particular,
we're going to look over the
model class of longin dynamics,
these will be inertial Orenstein
lindback processes. So you think
about that bead spring system.
And the objective here is from
observations of the
trajectories, essentially to
learn the stiffness, damping,
and the fluctuation related
terms and I'd like to do that
simultaneously using this
generative approach. The
challenge of course, with that
is dimensionality. These are
basically what the A observables
are I don't have a lot of time
to go into detail here. But you
can see that there are different
timescales at which those
different parameters are
sensitive. And that does play a
role in how you ultimately
formulate those, those training
protocols that I was referring
to. And I'll refer to the paper
again for some more in depth
discussion of that and be happy
to talk offline. So I just want
to point that out qualitatively,
you see that the way that will
manifest is when we're observing
and doing our training, if we
use, for example, the
conditionals. And the marginal
distributions, we're essentially
trading over observations that
are analogous to what I'm
showing here on the right. All
of this is done for a three
dimensional system, we're using
Rational quadratic kernels, I
should mention. And there's an
important role at this timescale
tau that we subsample on plays
in the training protocols. So
here's some quantitative
results, I'll just start with
the stiffness. You can see as we
vary tau, we're able to get this
quite accurately estimated. We
estimate its stiffness,
temperature damping
simultaneously, something
interesting happens in the
training and that just like with
maximum likelihood estimation,
there's a tendency to get pulled
towards a local minimizer, where
if you make the temperature very
large, of course, that will make
the training data quite
plausible on your model, but in
a suboptimal sense, one of the
nice things about the MMD that
we noticed is that once the
stiffness seems to get within
the right ballpark, it gets
pulled away from that kind of
local minimizer towards then the
correct temperature, as you're
seeing here in this particular
training run. And similarly with
the with the damping, um, so you
can see that there's also
interesting sensitivity on the
timescales here and just
comparing the different
protocols full conditional
marginals for a relatively large
sampling timescale versus a
small sampling timescale, you
can see that that plays
significant role in the accuracy
of the result, especially when
we look at something like the
conditionals, we get very good
accuracy for large timescales,
because there's sufficient
sensitivity to stiffness,
whereas if we go to a very small
timescales, essentially, that
learning signal that you would
get for determining stiffness
parameter is getting washed out
by other things like the thermal
fluctuations and the damping. So
so these are important hyper
parameters to keep in mind when
when training on these
stochastic systems, this dish
shows we get a very accurate
result for stiffness, we
similarly did a study with
temperature, this is all all the
parameters are changed, train
find simultaneously, we're
finding temperatures are much
more challenging for him to pin
down in detail, partly because
it can make up some of the
discrepancy between the models
by simply increasing the noise.
So if we don't have perfect
overlap between the training
samples and the generated
samples, it can kind of make
those things line up and agree.
So it might be picking up simply
on the sampling error. And
that's something we're currently
investigating. For many training
runs, we'll see the behavior
that we're seeing in terms of
epochs here, but for some of
them, they fail for the reasons
that I've limited. Similarly, we
can estimate the damping
parameter. And again, you see
some sensitivity there on the
timescales at which the dynamics
are probed. And so we see that
each case is different pros and
cons to those different training
protocols. But the SD, again,
you can mix and match are choose
between those approaches, as
well as tuning that timescale
tab. This is just showing real
quickly some results for
learning models where there's
unknown force laws. And so in
this case, we have observations
of a particle system. And we're
going to learn over the modeling
class, again, inertial launch
have on dynamics. And really the
objective here is to learn
neural network representation
for the unknown force law. Here,
I'll assume for now in this
study that the damping and the
thermal parameters are known.
But you also could try to learn
those simultaneously as well.
But again, you have that
challenge of these very sort of
high dimensional probability
spaces. But that graphical model
structure will be utilized to
exploit that those dependencies.
So here on the left is showing
the kinds of observations we
have, obviously many more than
just these three or four
samples. But just to show you
what the datasets look like that
we're training from, essentially
an ensemble of trajectories of
that nature, you'd be learning
from observing those dynamics
and the right learning over
chattery fragments. So do that
with the conditional and the
marginals. So this is just
showing some results. This is
the case of we're doing a radial
symmetric, double, well,
potential. This is showing the
force law that we're targeting.
We're using a neural network
representation for this neural
network. So we're training,
again, using the back custom
back propagation approach, as I
showed before, and this is
showing the model that we
learned. And really, I think the
advantage of these approaches is
that we're not reliant on things
like the system having Aquila
grated, which would be required
for for techniques that make use
of sort of a priori knowledge of
the marginals, we also can deal
with systems that are
potentially not in equilibrium,
because the primary driver of
the statistics that we're trying
to align are the the intrinsic
launch Yvonne dynamics and so on
the right is just showing
training the double well
potential. And then the way
we're going to characterize this
is in terms of the L one error
of the radial distribution
function. This is not something
that was used in the training,
which is to have on reliable
test errors, which would govern
a lot of the statistics
ultimately of that model that
you've learned. And I'll just
show some quick results for
that. This is just showing on
the left the the learned model.
So you can see that we get
viable long time simulators. And
on the right is, is showing the
other training dataset. And
again, this is just showing some
quantitative results. And again,
we did some studies, as we vary
the temporal sampling parameter.
So I won't go into a lot of
detail there, which is to show
that yeah, we're able to learn
nonlinear force laws. And we're
kind of pushing this in a number
of directions to improve both
the dimensionality and the
complexity of the problems that
we can deal with. But I hope
this gives kind of a proof of
concept of some of the recent
work that we've been doing. I'd
be happy to talk more about that
offline. I'll refer you to the
papers. So thanks again for
having me. Look forward to
continuing discussions.